anh
alo cho con à
Ừ Ừ chắc ở có thể là
chắc có thể là kiểu công an tố cáo thật
tôi không biết nữa
con
mèo ca thằng YouTube nó đánh bản quyền
game à cái này cho mình biết à
ừ ừ
anh
Na Na lời thôi pasle để hôm nay nhá về
học hôm nay thì mình sẽ dạy cho các bạn
về
ở những cái Element nói cho đây đổ lại
những cái con sót lại của ra Spirit gần
ngờ mình có đề cập nó đom và bom đó là
do comment nữa object mình nhớ đại khái
nó là thế không nhớ chính xác tên nó làm
đâu nhưng mua đồ cái gì đó nữa
đó em này và bom này thì cái này nó sẽ
hiểu đại khái là đó của mình các bạn chỉ
cần thực ra chỉ cần nhớ cái này nó của
mình này là cái này nó khác là closer
to track 1 cái đó của mình Jack và một
cái forex Còn đằng sau nó là mua đồ hình
cái gì đó thì nó không cần quan tâm nữa
mình mình không cần quan tâm Đấy mình
chỉ cần biết phân biệt hai hàng ngày nó
khác nhau Điểm gì
thì À cái đó của mình update thì mình
nói trước bởi vì mình đã từng dạy qua
các bạn về cái đấy rồi
ờ ờ
à à
Lê Minh Tuyết à
Ừ
cái đó của mình nó trái nó chính là cái
đó của mình xong rồi ghét lên mình body
các thử này
chị nhà đang ngồi nhóp nhép bên cạnh mà
ừ ừ
xe trái quy định quá à
ờ ờ
cái đó của mình update thì cho đó của
mình chậm cái mình body đó các bạn biết
rồi thật sự là mình cho nó 1 cái đít như
này say quá đi là kiểu kết quả đúng
nhưng mà khi mình là sau đó thì mặc định
khi mới vào trang web thì nó sẽ chạy
đoạn ra Swift là kéo
getelementbyid sau hồi vào cái kết quả
này xong rồi nh alo để mà in ra những gì
đó dụng là xin chào các bạn nào ạ
Như này đây mình chạy thử cái này thì
các bạn sẽ thấy là nó sẽ hiển thị ra chữ
xin chào các bạn kể cả sau Dù là Lúc đầu
Lúc đầu HP mà lòng mình không hề có vẻ
đoạn Xin chào các bạn mà sẽ dùng giá
Suite để mà gọi đình cái thằng đặt hàng
ngày tháng đó của mình này thì a khái
niệm đó của mình này như mình ở từng nói
nó cứ lần này chỉ là tài liệu và cụ thể
nó là cả cái cái cái tài liệu HTML này
cả cái pha ra đấy Nó là một cái đó của
mình
và kể các em mình Bay đi là bản chất nó
sẽ gọi Bến thằng đối tượng theo ID của
đó Linh trước và mình còn có thể biết
được em là có thể ghét bạn airman Bike
nhiều cái nữa là sử ở đây mình sẽ có chữ
get này rồi phát ra cái nó sẽ gợi ý bài
test nêm rất à theo tên thẻ nhưng mà các
bạn thấy thêm chết tức là nó xuống nhiều
đúng ạ ví dụ là tên thẻ thì ở đây có thẻ
đi chẳng hạn
thì thì giả sử bây giờ mình sẽ đặt một
cái biến là đít hiểu Anh hiểu nó xuống
nhiều đi Đây đúng loạn và để và để cho
Muốn hiển thị cái đít đầu tiên gia sư ở
đây cho dù tia có một cái đít thôi nha
các bạn bể và muốn hiển thị cái đít kết
quả này anh ra được lại như này thì các
bạn phải đít như này tại vị trí không
nghĩa đầu tiên mà chẳng Winner HTML là
xin chào em ạ Đấy thì nó mới ra chứ nếu
mà các bạn ít của như này thậm chữa gipp
kiểu như thế này bằng như thế này xin
chào thật
thế nhưng mỗi khi mình làm là sự không
có đoạn này đi thì đã sao nó sẽ không ra
được ạ Tại sao lại không ra các bạn sẽ
nghĩ là có thể là cái này thì nó sẽ hiểu
là cho tất cả các đít là sử này đi cho
tất cả đít đều in chữ kết quả không được
à mới gọi nhưng mà không bản chất là nó
không có cơ chế kiểu là
chấm chấm nh Alo nó sẽ nằm cho nó sẽ cho
cái Thục Cái này gọi là tăng trưởng hàm
này nó không dùng được cho số nhiều được
không ạ Nó chỉ dùng cho từng đối tượng
một thôi mình để xin lỗi các bạn xem nhé
đây Các bạn thấy con show này
ra nó không đi ra lỗi gì đâu
xe tải nhưng mà rõ ràng Các bạn thấy
thực ra rồi nó về cơ bản cái loại này
sai rồi nó sẽ không không áp dụng cho
kiểu này nó sẽ phải là kiểu tại vị trí
thứ không lại trả lại thì nó sẽ đi là dự
trữ xin chào Vậy
còn nếu mà các bạn muốn cho tất cả cái
beat này cùng
cùng in cùng in ra chữ xin chào ấy thì
các bạn ở chạy vòng lập nó bản bản chất
nó là nó làm ảnh mà đúng ạ thì các bạn
sẽ chạy 1 lặp thôi mình led đi đấy bằng
ngay sau đó vòng là pô trở lại nét Y =
không ạ Các bạn nhớ đoạn này rồi nói y
nhỏ hơn
ít chậm le này và đi + + nào ạ Đấy và
bít lại phải trừ y mình sẽ inner HTML
bằng Xin chào nha đó thì mới được
thứ hai nữa htmls tôi chưa thử cái trò
này bây giờ để gửi cho
Nhưng mà chắc không được đâu ạ
à à
Ừ
đấy đại khá như thế Ngoài ra còn những
điều gì nữa ngoài ra còn nó sẽ có thêm
là ví dụ là Bye classname này
và còn bay theo nhiều cái nữa như là đại
Khái ở đây Nếu các bạn muốn tra thì các
bạn sẽ tra bom Chow Swift thì nó sẽ ra
những cái những cái đó comment mà nó như
thế nào những đại khái Ở đây các bạn có
thể là bản chất nó đó là
thì nó là cái tài liệu cái tài liệu HTML
này vẫn phải được lót đã đồ lót xong đã
thì cái đo này mới chạy và nó sẽ chạy
dựa trên những cái những cái có sẵn ở
trong HTML những cái kiểu như thế này để
các bạn tự tại sao lại rầm tôi phải đề
cập đến vụ tài liệu đoàn các thứ Bởi vì
bây giờ mình sẽ nhảy sang bom chẳng hạn
bom thì các bạn sẽ thấy về cơ bản thì
mình đã từng dùng qua mình một hàm của
nó rồi nó chính là Hà Plus là sự đây À
xin chào các bạn ạ
Bạn nhớ Hà mới lớp hả em ạ
xe tải mỗi xe tải lại trang là sẽ hiển
thị ra cả đây thì trên mỗi trình duyệt
khác nhau Nó sẽ hiển thị khác nhau
tủ
lạnh video vậy
à à
em
vừa tự động tắt luôn
Nó đang từ chối mình à
à à à Tự nhiên xin mãi Tự nhiên khó trò
không có ngăn không cho ra Speed tự động
chạy tới xịn đấy thì các bạn thể hiển
thị thông báo khác nhau đúng ạ bởi vì
bản chất bom đó Thế nó liên quan đến
Tĩnh trình duyệt
và nếu mà ghi đầy đủ của nó sẽ là nguyên
đâu chấm Alice như thế này
ý cho con là các bạn được viết tắt kiểu
nhà nhưng mà các bạn sẽ hiểu là nó nó
phải kèm hiện chữ Windows nó mới chuột
đó là bom đâu ạ
đi thi à cái cái cái Vũ bom này thì Bom
mà nó sẽ có hỗ trợ những cái gì Nó là
kiểu liên quan đến trình duyệt chứ không
liên quan tài liệu thức à thông báo này
điều hướng nhảy Sang trang khác này mở
ra tab mới lại hai à ờ ờ
thế hiển thị ra một cái để cho các bạn
Nhập vào đây giống kẹp lock lại chẳng
hạn mình hay Anh dùng cái này
à
Nhập vào tuổi của bạn
kiểu ngay
khi
đó nó sẽ hiển thị ra cái các bạn Nhập
vào đấy ra xử với mình có thể sử dụng
được chín cái mà
bạn ấy nhập xong rồi mình sẽ ở lớp ra
một cái đó chẳng hạn
bạn tuổi gì đó cậu được tuổi thì này
nhìn này được ạ
1000 cái này không phải liên quan hệ
điều hành hiện điều hành chuẩn bị không
phải thêm chữ s thì nó mới quý đâu Cái
này liên quan đến
trình duyệt mà
anh nhìn nó là bom liên quan trình duyệt
à
thì các bạn sẽ nói đúng đấy
Windows nó viết tắt của cửa sổ trình
duyệt thương mày hệ điều hành
đúng rồi Nhiều không Vẫn bị nhầm hệ điều
hành Windows là thiếu chữ s Windows sẽ
thêm chữ S II
à à
à À đấy Đấy vừa rồi mình hẹn hò qua phải
Bom và đom thì cả kiến thức hôm nay động
trị tương đối thế thôi
Ừ để các bạn là biết hiểu rõ toàn bộ về
ra Swift nó sẽ gồm tất cả những cái gì
sau đó Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
thì các bạn bảo Chữa bài tập à
vợ rồi mình lý Chó sủa
Chó nhà mình Nó hơi ngu nó cứ thấy chủ
lắm suốt à
có một cách bảo vệ bảo vệ lãnh thổ
ờ
ờ bà này mình mình sẽ trả lời những câu
hỏi trước đã Đầu tiên thì mình nói qua
với khái niệm Smart Còn Như ấu cũng Tưng
thấy mình nói cái này và cũng thắc mắc
Smart là gì Smart thành tôi phát ra mà
không đúng lắm chứ cậu nha mới vào đại
khái đối như mình hiểu thì sẽ
hôm nay sẽ có bài tập đấy
nó Nó là kiểu na ná giống như kiểu ông
ông đang học đại học nếu và ông xuống
làm những vài có một mặc cảm thiết tha
cho bài mẫu giáo rồi ạ nghĩa Trình độ
này trước đây cái sẽ khái niệm Smart bật
và mình đề cập vụ Smart vào đây nữa đó
liên quan việc là mình thấy da có rất
nhiều bạn làm bài tập của mình ở trên
cái trang cái cái bồ rất là tốt ở bãi
làm giao diện lẫn cả code các thứ trong
ngày rất chuyên nghiệp nhưng có vẻ các
bạn này vẫn chịu khó làm Và thậm chí Xem
livestream của mình thế nên là mình cảm
thấy ạ
áo kiểu ở không biết méo cái vào đây
với mục đích gì có thể là cậu cũng muốn
học hỏi thêm kiến thức Bởi vì nếu là
mình thì mình cũng đôi khi nếu có thời
gian đây mình cũng sẽ học họ hình nền
Đức từ người khác có thể người đấy trình
độ cũng thể chưa biết thế nào có thể
thậm chí bằng mình nhưng mà học hỏi thêm
vẫn luôn tốt mà đúng ạ ạ
ờ ờ
Ừ cái câu
a z đi mình mới hết nào là điện thì vừa
rồi mình có nói qua về những mẹ mấy
thước rồi
các bạn tự tham khảo xem à Cái nào Ổn
nhá việc các bạn thì mình thấy à được
dùng nhiều nhất thì sẽ là két bye đi
hoặc ghét bye
tác nêm classname Thôi để ba cái sẽ được
dùng nhiều
truyền tham số vào để in ra một cái gì
đó đây mình sẽ thử bây giờ
thì
cái phăng phăng chân đấy Cái phong trần
à
Ừ mình mới chỉ dạy các bạn có bạn vì
việc cả phân trần nó
mình mình Mịch mới chỉ dùng một phanh
chân để mà làm gì đó Bây giờ sự mình
dùng tận hai phân xử
em chẳng ạ thì nó sẽ như sao cho sửa
nhật số
vì đó đi em ạ sẽ input này
Vì sao nằm mơ
adi đà fet nằm mơ trả lại ạ
đi soi mình sẽ có một cái nút
A
[âm nhạc]
wondrous là Hiển thị chào ạ ạ
à
[âm nhạc]
nếu nếu mà thực ra chuẩn đấy chuẩn của
cái hàng này thì được nhà hàng này chỉ
có tác dụng là hiển thị ra tôi à Còn gì
mà lấy cái giá trị số về thì mình nên
tặng một tháng nữa
[âm nhạc]
mình sẽ kiểu như sau mình sẽ là kiểu tại
một cái hàm nữa Ở đây Hà đấy sẽ là
ờ ờ
khi phóng sinh là mình lấy số chẳng hạn
ạ
ừ ừ
I
read à số bằng đau mình em mình body
Futsal
Nhìn trông có vẻ hơi dài dòng một tí
ạ Và bây giờ mình muốn lấy cái giá trị
số này về từ cái hàng này thì mình có
thể Return số
Còn nếu mà các bạn thích tắt hơn thì các
bạn có thể là không khai báo biến các
bạn Return hàng để hai này cũng được như
thế này cho nó ngắn thì đây sẽ là led số
bằng lấy số này đúng ạ sau đó thì mình
sẽ chị việc tới giờ là in ra kết quả
vào một cái kết quả nha trở lại
à à
các bạn đã nhập số soi sau đó thì + nuôi
sống à trả lại ạ
anh
em cái đít và cái ID kết quả đi à
à à
để
hiển thị lại ạ
khi sex
Ừ anh em đi nhà nghỉ à
ở đây kiểu như thế này các bạn sẽ thấy
là đây là một cách theo kiểu là
ờ ờ một cách là các bạn sẽ gọi đến cái
hòm khác để lấy giá trị về sau đó các
bạn sử dụng giá trị đấy thì ít ra kết
quả có cái khác nữa đó là các bạn lấy
giá trị về sau đó Các bạn truyền giá trị
vào trong hàng này gửi tin nhắn kết quả
cũng được Giả sử bây giờ mình sẽ đổi nó
thành nét số còn đây bằng như thế này
sau đó đi gọi đến đó làm hiển thị và
truyền số và trong như thế này ở đây nó
sẽ gọi hàm lấy số trước đi sau đó từ lấy
số sẽ gọi đến sẽ lấy giá trị này xong
rồi gọi đến hiển thị hay mình sẽ chuyển
số vào trong như thế này vào đây sẽ kiểu
ngay thôi thì các bạn thấy thôi ta kết
quả nó như nhau đúng ạ thì ở đây nó cách
để mà gọi hai hàm đó thể gọi đình nhau
đó là gọi tên Hàn xong rồi mở ngoặc ra
như thế này có thể truyền vào giá trị
hoặc không chuyển đổi rồi Các bạn thấy
đề cập mình để cập cả hai ví dụ đồng
đoạn là có thể là họ đến không cần
truyền giá trị gì Và nó sẽ Return về một
cái giá trị để mình Ừ đấy thì mình ninza
hay là mình sẽ truyền giá trị vào trong
như thế này thôi Chỉ đơn giản là yêu nó
giá trị ấy thôi đúng ạ Thế
tiếp theo là thêm một cái khái niệm nữa
nếu mà nhiều ông không để ý tôi tôi tôi
đang nói theo khái niệm về bên c c + +
và Java và cả gia Suite Thôi nhá Không
nói ngôn ngữ khai thế nhưng mấy âm Nếu
mày không để ý kỹ thì thực ra đối với
ngôn ngữ lập trình thì chỗ ấy với
Android nó được nó được
áo kiểu hiểu là tương đồng với nhau xem
như tôi thấy là như thế bởi vì sao Bởi
vì nếu mà Mấy ông Để ý kỹ bên tạm biệt
canxi ạ nếu mà ông không biết thì bên
xin nó sẽ khai báo biến và như thế nào ạ
Con sẽ khai báo biến là kiểu biển chuỗi
nó sẽ là
đầu tiên là khai báo với mảng miếng sidi
màng miễn xui thì nó sẽ ra kiểu tranh ah
trả lại ạ
Ừ đúng nhỉ Tôi nhớ không lầm ở như thế
này ở sau đó thì khai báo là độ dài của
cái mạng đấy là sự là mười nhé còn là
còn bên còn chuỗi chú ấy ở bên Xi nó vẫn
khai báo thì cậu như thế này nó sẽ là
xui nữa song Cũng có thể là chúc chú ấy
đây là dụng cụ mạnh cho chuẩn nha à
thế mà cũng kiểm nha cac + + e tôi không
Tôi lâu học rồi cũng nhớ đấy thì mẹ mới
ông sẽ thấy thời gian mày Cái này là
tương đồng theo kiểu lại là chuỗi với
mạng nó vẫn đều khai báo
chế độ dài giới hạn lớn nhất của nó và
mà Đúng là trong ra Swift nó cũng sẽ
kiểu Tuy là nó không cần khai báo cái
kiểu à độ dài lớn nhất nếu mà nhưng mà
nó sẽ có kiểu như thế này
thì
nó sẽ là kiểu à
ừ ừ
thì
nó sẽ là kiểu bây giờ ông có một cái chỗ
gì đó và ông muốn in phần tử tại vị trí
thuê bao nhiêu tương tự giống mặt luôn
cũng được Giả sử Bây giờ tôi sẽ là nhập
chuỗi bất kỳ em ạ
đây mà sẽ thấy in bút hightech nhá Ừ
à à
chị sẽ có ai đi à Lại input chỗ ấy đi
Tự nhiên tôi xóa lại kia đi còn 1 click
là hình chị này
hiển thị
hàng đúng rồi Tôi khuyên bé ông lạc nên
kiểu ghi tiếng Việt có dấu các thứ ở mọi
chỗ cho xí nghiệp nhé Và đây là phòng
trình là Hiển thị lại
nét chú ấy bằng à
xe
tải trò chơi nếu mà chỉ đơn giản là đâu
Comment chấm gastambide ạ
anh hai đi kết quả in a cái chỗ anh Bình
đã gõ thì các bạn biết rồi đấy ạ ạ
ở
đây lúa nhưng bên Lần này thì mình sẽ có
thể là chuỗi tại vị trí không vẫn được
này ạ
ơi các bạn hãy ạ
ở đây
thì có bạn sẽ thấy là chuỗi nó sẽ được
tính là nhưng mà đúng ạ Nó sẽ là Nhưng
mà đối với da Swift nó như thế và thực
ra với nhiều ngôn ngữ lập trình như mình
vừa nói xí + + ạ Vẫn cả sava mình nhớ
Thế thì sẽ sẽ đôi khi ở sẽ hiểu là là
kiểu hay hành động tương tự là giống
nhau thì cái việc là chỗ vậy mà tương tự
thế
Ừ đấy thì à tại sao mình phải đề cập vụ
đấy Ở đây bởi vì tức là có những cái Hàn
gì của bên bên mạ chị cũng sẽ có bên chỗ
và ngược lạ nó là như thế nghĩa là mình
nói về vụ những hàng phổ biến của của
Android và chú ếch là sự là hàm lấy độ
dài của chuỗi cũng sẽ đã áp dụng với độ
dài của mảnh mình thử cho các bạn xem
nhé mình sẽ in chuỗi chậm le này
Ừ
cái này chắc ạ 6 đúng ạ Chưa mình cho nó
là cái mảnh thì thực ra nó cũng sẽ là
sáu là sự là mình sẽ có nét Mà bao
123456 em nha
À không Ừ ừ ngồi nó vẫn là xấu như thế
này à
Anh tắt máy đi thật lo lắng
Các bạn thấy à mình sẽ cảm hai tên biến
vào là được rối loạn
hàm nó vẫn thế
Vì sao mày nó sẽ hiểu dùm chung như thế
này đúng ạ và có nhiều cái nộ tương tự
như thế nó sẽ có vài cái khác thôi
Đấy là cũng là lý do mà lần trước Nếu
các bạn để ý kĩ lần trước và mình in
được ra cả cái mạc kiểu như này à
anh ấy mà
tại sao mà
có phải các bạn sửa xong ra Suite và các
bạn phải tải lại sang nhé Ừ đấy các bạn
thấy là nó in ra thành dạng chuỗi và
cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy như thế này bởi
vì sao vì nó đang ép nó thành chuỗi đúng
ạ Chứ vài ngôn ngữ lập trình sẽ báo lỗi
những bà đổ về ra Swift nó hiểu mạng nó
cũng còn chất nó là chỗ ấy cái thành ra
nó làm cái trò này à
Ừ ok vừa rồi mình sẽ nói qua thêm một tí
nữa về những cái hàm
thì các bạn có gì Các bạn sẽ tra về
trở lên w3school này để xem nốt bởi vì
có rất nhiều cái thứ mà mình không thể
dạy sau về nó được giống như là mình đã
dạy mình đã đòi quà tuyệt và speak mình
chỉ dạy các bạn mới biết virus Mà buổi
hôm trước các bạn làm cái đếch các bạn
đã đi qua rồi và sau mùa hôm nay mình sẽ
nhảy sang bên p&j chuyên sâu bên đấy hôn
ở bướm
à Còn bây giờ mình sẽ nói nốt về cái á
có sai chính tả
vợ chồng GS thì mình đã từng nói qua vụ
là nếu mà các bạn có sai mình cái gì đó
Kiểu như này
thì nó sẽ hiển thị cảnh báo đây nhưng mà
đôi khi nó không nhỉ định cảnh báo thì
các bạn sẽ không biết không biết xử lý
nhà thì lần trước mình còn đây Cập là
các bạn sẽ phải
phải xóa hoặc biến nó thành chú thích
từng với dòng ngay để xem nó có chạy đến
cái dòng là bất ký không các bạn hãy
chơi chó có show giống như hôm trước
mình đi cập
đến một cách dbox mình không hiểu các
phương pháp đi bắt lại lắm Nó đi bớt
theo cậu dạng là in giá trị ở từng vòng
đấy trợ cho hình khi là đến cái rọc là
tự nhiên nó không in ra cái nữa thì
chứng tỏ ở lò của mình đây cả thế
đó là sự mình như này
em thấy ennis số một của bọn mình để cái
này đến cuối là sự ra sự như thế là sự
mấy cái Trên này nó có vấn đề gì đấy nó
không nhìn ra được số 1 các bạn sẽ biết
được Tại sao đúng không ạ kiểm ngay
trong trường hợp này như mình đã nói thì
mai mà cái này nó nó báo lỗi cảnh báo
mình nhưng mà có vài trường hợp mà không
cảnh báo gì ở mình đâu bởi biệt
ở lợn Nói chung ở không không trông chờ
được và cái Nguyệt và hiển thị lỗi ở
ngay mà Mình chỉ trông chờ việc à nó
không in được ra giá trị như này thức à
mà họ chết ở một cái dòng đó rồi đúng ạ
cách để đi bốc không phải mỗi da súp nữa
đấy cách để đi bắt mình thấy là khó ổi
các bạn phải biết đi bất Vì thời gian
cốt các bạn chỉ có tốn đó luôn là bài
toán 28 mưa đấy ạ Đó là các bạn sẽ tốn
20 phần trăm thời gian để ngồi cốt ra
một cái tính năng gì đó thôi và 80 phần
trăm của loại các bạn đi bất cứ mùi sửa
lỗi thế nên đôi khi đôi khi trong một
vài trường hợp và nhiều người thường anh
nói là kiểu thả đập đi xây lại còn làm
nhanh hơn đấy Bởi vì thực ra đi để mà
một thời gian sửa đó thì mất gấp 4 lần
thời gian để ngồi làm lại cái mới đây là
các bạn sẽ và cân nhắc thời vụ là
Ừ
nếu mà có một dự án ở đó thuê các bạn về
các bạn ngồi sửa thì các bạn có khi là
các bạn được nghĩ nó ngon ăn theo kiểu
đã bởi vì đã làm hết từ A đến Z rồi mình
chỉ việc sửa một ít thôi không Không có
chuyện đấy đâu các bạn là mình mình phải
chia sẻ cái đấy vì à Nhiều nhiều bạn của
mình tôi bị dính vào cái vụ đấy
ở đấy có thêm một lý do nữa tao khuyên
mày ông vào cũng thì xe grab ngay từ ban
đầu để mà kiểu mình là là những thằng
đầu tiên vào mình cốt những một trong
những cái đầu tiên và chạy và biết được
chốt đang đang đến đâu ấy chứ không phải
là không phải là kiểu nhảy đùng và một
phát có một cái người ta mấy nghìn mình
file rồi nhưng mà mình nhìn nhầm cốc nữa
Một file mà mình đi làm cốc rồi nhá
Nhưng đây đó là mấy nghìn file đấy đấy
Mấy ông không phải hiểu được miễn không
biết sửa đâu nữa Đấy nó phải chịu mà đặc
biệt là thôi thời gian đầu vào thời gian
mấy ông một đã học việc nghĩa béo nhưng
chưa hiểu được rất nhiều cái Ê mấy ông
gặp mấy đồng đấy giờ choáng nên là
cho nên vào những công ty Xá Bắc thời
gian đầu mình vẫn thấy rất hợp lý mình
mình sẽ
Hà Tĩnh Mình sẽ kêu à tự tự mình là
người Cốt lại còn gọi này ổn hơn
em tự mình tạo ra bất cũng được
anh không cho tôi hình như tôi nói qua
vụ là lưu và chia sẻ cái nick pass của
virus rồi nhưng mà tôi vẫn đi lại đây để
mà
Ồ tôi định nhà chia sẻ cho mấy ông về
cái đoạn mà tôi làm relax bằng là
a
black Facebook
[âm nhạc]
nhưng mà tí sắc là tôi sẽ đổi nó thành
bài tập vậy các bạn sẽ phải dùng với
lách gì mà lấy ra được
Hay đi từ một cái link bất kỳ tín tôi sẽ
gửi cho mày tập đây nếu như Nhắc tôi nữa
tối hay quên
để tạo ra đủ côn trùng ngoài nữa cá lưu
không trùng này thì hôm trước có bạn hỏi
về vụ radu không chụp thôi chắc là chữ
mỗi có vậy thôi
thì các bạn nhớ về cái vụ hôm trước có
bài tập là kiểu bấm nó cái núp sau đó
thì nó sẽ là đun ra các số ngẫu nhiên
rồi có bạn thắc mắc à Thế các em giả sử
của em muốn khi mà ra được những cây số
ngẫu nhiên này nó không trùng nhau nữa
thì sao ạ thì bản chất là mình sẽ truyền
nó vào trong một cái mảnh đúng ạ sau đó
đi mình mình kiểm tra xem là cái số này
có tồn tại có tồn tại song cái mạng hay
không Nếu mà không Nếu mà có thì mình sẽ
ra Đun lại sắp nữa Chẳng thế
là sự đây mình sẽ có đầu tiên cho mạnh
chống lại ạ
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ là cái bấm nút đi Bấm
nút thì nó sẽ là hiển thị ra là được cái
mạng gồm mà
cứ mặc định chạy đến mưa đấy nhá Ừ
à à
ở
đây mình sẽ là ờ Nghĩa làm gì ở mình
muốn mình muốn in là mười số Xẽ nhãn thế
đầu tiên là mình cứ chuyển nếu mà mình
muốn làm kẹo đơn giản thì mình sẽ là
đầu tiên là cho nét số ngẫu nhiên
khai báo trước cái số này sau đó đi số
ngẫu nhiên sẽ bằng map
chấm ra Đun này
là sử giáo dục và xấu gì đó sau đó thì
đầy nó vào trong
mà sau đó đi mình sẽ cho comment chấm
ghét em mình
bài đi Kết quả đây
Windows tim em bằng mạnh và sự thế
anh ta kiểm nha số này thì các bạn thấy
mát trận manu nó sẽ ra số giờ xấu bởi vì
nó sẽ là dao động từ không đến một thôi
Đây mình sẽ là
map.co hydro Tùy các bạn là làm cho nên
làm tròn xuống loạn nhận với 10 vậy
nếu nhân với mưa ở đây nó sẽ hiểu là dao
động từ
không cho đến mưa ấy luôn à
ở
Bạch các bạn sẽ thấy là nó vỡ sẽ in ra
10 số nhưng mà có thể số có thể trùng
giống như là số bà đấy Đang trùng nói ba
lần nữa bọn cái cách tốt ở đây nó sẽ là
kiểm tra là nếu mà cái trong này mà
a
two pictures thì nó vẫn không thể nào mà
làm tròn đến số kiểu trong phạm vi từ 1
đến 10 ra lúc ạ ạ
ờ ờ
à à
Ừ
thì thì bây giờ giả sự là nếu mà trong
trường hợp kiểu ngày thì các bạn sẽ cần
ra lại cái số này để ra được có số khác
nếu mà trong trường hợp mạng này có rồi
loạn thì các bạn Thể tra là khái niệm y
dress which thì kiểm tra xem nó có tồn
tại trong aleph-0 khái niệm đó là Hà Min
Plus như này đây mình sẽ là
ít mà trầm in Plus này
thấy số ngẫu nhiên này là sẽ các bạn đó
đun rồi ra số lượng nhiên thôi và
Ừ
nếu mà kiểu ngày nó ra rồi các bạn lại
phải phải ra nô lại nó cứ thế và đoạn
này Nếu thế thì nó sẽ vào lọc vòng lạc
Ra luôn mình khi nào mà xa con số không
phải là ngẫu nhiên nữa là không không
nằm trong mạng nữa
Thực ra nếu mà số từ 1 đến 10 thì nếu mà
các bạn random như thế mãi thì chắc chắn
nó sẽ hiểu
100 đến 9 à
em ngồi đó bắt buộc cái số đây 049 các
thứ cái mình đổi Đây là số từ 1 đến 100
đi
Ừ nhưng mày không hiểu vì tôi mà đâu vợ
ạ
a cho sẽ phải chạy vòng lặp đi bằng lặp
lại để thể nào đến được ra con số kiểu
không không nằm trong màn này đi thôi
à à
Ừ thì cách cách Bởi vì À cái vòng lặp
đấy lặp đi lặp lại khi nào đến giờ nghỉ
thôi thành ra là các bạn thể chơi trò
này đó là các bạn không biết được vòng
là phải chạy vì khi nào dừng thì có bạn
sẽ là của anh như thế này và Dubai cũng
được đu quay đi bởi vì kiểu gì cũng chạy
nhất một lần đúng không ạ ạ
ở đầu tiên thì nếu dạt sự là không có
thì mình truyền vào như thế này ạ
em ở đâu love bình tĩnh
Nếu không có hijack này Còn nếu không
thì mình tiếp tục chạy cứ thể thay thế
ngoài đấy trong chưa quay đây là chú
bạn ơi sẽ hiểu như sau đó là kiểu nó sẽ
chạy ngẫu nhiên liên tục cho mình khi
nào mạng đấy không không chứa cái thang
này thì mình Black thể ngắt cái vòng lặp
lại sau đó thì mới chuyên bác không ạ
Anh từ 1 đến 100 thì chắc chắn là nó
cũng hiếm có trường hợp nào trùng lắp
như là từ 1 đến 10 gửi nhà nghỉ Tôi nghĩ
nó sẽ
lại các bạn sẽ thấy số đó sẽ không à
không Để chồng được không ạ
Ừ ok sạn
cha
[âm nhạc]
mẹ ông đừng đổi số này thành cho 1 đến 5
nhé sẽ chạy vòng lặp đu quay đến chết
cái giới hạn từ 1 đến từ 0 đến 5 ở đó mà
rõ ràng là mạnh của ông chứa 10 phần tử
chạy treo luôn mãi yêu thế thôi chết tôi
là lần nữa à
Ừ
đấy đại khái là như thế
ờ ờ
ở cái trường hợp chữa bài tập này thì
chắc là mình sẽ đã để một câu sao đi cho
bạn rồi Hôm sau mình lại chữa nhé
thì tại sao mấy giờ để có xanh như thế
thì mình vẫn cảm thấy bây giờ mình đã
tháo hức với vụ làm tool Facebook à
à Hôm nay tôi sẽ chia sẻ không về cái
tool Facebook mà đúng ạ ạ
ở đầu tiên là trước hết là tôi à
ờ ờ
chứ
không phải đăng nhập Facebook cả Đừng
gọi
à à
đầu tiên các bạn phải đăng nhập vào
Facebook tại sao như thế đăng nhập vào
Facebook sau đó thì các bạn để sáng để
trang your love spell Trần facebook.com
thường là
mặc định của tôi tôi đăng nhập rồi và
tôi cũng đăng ký rồi
anh ấn vào bên bố đấy
ô tô đắt lắm nhỉ
à
À đúng rồi Mát gì Nói cho cẩn mát hay gì
đó tôi đăng nhập rồi tôi đăng ký là đứa
Pearl rồi đăng ký đi học không mất thì
cả đam mê Ông ấy ông ấy đăng ký thôi sau
đó mới ông tạo với áp
tạm một cái áo ở trên này
hồi đấy đã tạm nhiều app thì mà test lắm
Sau đó thì chuẩn máy làm mì ông sẽ vào
bên grab grab api này ạ
ở đầu tiên thì tôi xin phép nói qua một
tí lại một lần nữa cho bạn nào chưa biết
rồi Cái Token được ạ thì đầu tiên là hồi
trước khi mà vào và chăng là nhân này
Anh bảo chắc là nhân này hồi đấy Ăn
console thu xong rồi gõ Tìm Ea như thế
này bạn sẽ ra một đoạn Token nó to Kem
gọi tao Panda à
Ừ ok đấy sẽ tàu ngầm full khuya nhiều
người thương ai bảo thế
cho mượn tiền tao cái phân quyền là cái
gì đó Đó là kiểu Token có đầy đủ quyền
của một người dùng có thể đăng nhập vào
người dùng đấy quá à là Trung Hoa có thể
đăng nhập được thẳng luôn đấy bởi vì nó
là cực kỳ luôn đó là kiểu à anh vào vào
nick người đấy không cần biết email mật
khẩu
ở miệng từng nói qua bộ đấy là tại sao
Facebook gọi làm ra cái vụ đấy không chỉ
mượn Facebook mà gần như bây giờ thằng
nào mà có người áp điện thoại thì nó đều
phải có cơ chế đấy bởi vì có gì đấy là
cơ chế cậu để bà những người áp khác có
thể gọi đến server để kiểm tra xe
máy của bạn đúng không ạ
ờ ờ máy của bạn
Cái nổi đến cái nồi đến
Facebook để mà kiểu
thao tác mọi thứ tăng đăng ảnh là hai
hay là bình luận hay các sự thử mà các
bạn thấy không cần phải đăng nhập lại
vân vân cái vụ không cần đời đó nghiệp
lại thì bạn chất là trên máy các bạn
không phải cứ mỗi lần gửi cái thao tác
lên là sẽ là sẽ lại đăng nhập lại lạnh
rồi cải email và mật khẩu đâu không Và
sẽ gửi qua một cái khái niệm vào top kem
kiểu nghe giọng nói là dùng cuộc thi
thôi tao kenkouki nó cũng giống nhau
thôi
thì thì
Em bảo cho các bạn cứ Hình dung là to
Kem nó sẽ thay như cái thẻ thành viên
các bạn để bảo thể truy cập được vào
nick của một cái gì đó và có tương đối
tương đối quyền thôi vô cái tao quen hồi
đấy rồi đấy mà xem được trên trang cá
nhân này nó phun Quyến
và thứ là mình đã từng nói qua cả các vụ
ở Facebook Hồi đấy bị
em có cái tính năng là xem xem bản thân
mình với tư cách người khác như này
là sửa tôi xem tư cách của bạn bè thôi
chẳng hạn cho tự nhiên tôi hồi lại ở Hồi
đấy có hacker mỏ ra được là xem mình với
tư cách của ABC chuẩn cân su để xem được
tao kem của người kia và đặc biệt tao
khen một người kia còn là phun quyền nữa
thành ra là nó thành ra là hồi hồi đấy
Facebook phải tạm gỡ cái tính năng này
đi cũng như là đăng xuất 5 triệu rồi đấy
nhớ 595 triệu tài khoản người dùng vô
hiệu hóa 5 triệu tài khoản người dùng để
mà cho gỡ cái to khen của thằng hacker
kia là nó ngồi nó rò ra được đi
còn bây giờ rất khó để cho Ken Facebook
nhưng mà tí rồi sẽ chỉ yêu mày ông cách
Nếu mà chỉ trong mấy ông khách về mà lấy
cho kem rồi đồng nghĩa việc làm méo và
để lộ nó ra thì mấy ông Tý cũng sẽ phải
làm đúng như tôi đó là mấy ông phải ở
phải
Anh thường chuẩn cách đó là vô hiệu hóa
tài khoản nhưng mà để chắc cú hơn để
bước lên đổi mật khẩu đã cả đăng xuất
khỏi mọi thiết bị rồi đó thì mới vôi hóa
tài khoản đó chắc
đôi khi đổ mật khẩu là không đủ của Vì
nghe nói là có một cái loại tóc em nữa
là loại to ké nữa
Nó kiểu có ghen kiểu
đó chuông ạ Mình nghe giờ chị câu nói về
chức vụ to get to Kem chống lại đổi mật
khẩu chưa thể nghĩa nó vẫn sống nhưng mà
các bạn đổi xong mật khẩu à ở
[âm nhạc]
đại khái vừa rồi Tao quen như thế ba cái
tóc em mình đang cho các bạn xem ở đây
nó không phải tóc ai cũng quyền Token
này là to kem từ cái app đọc em tự app
Tức là sao Nghĩa giả sử là các bạn phải
có rất nhiều trang mưa có nút đăng nhập
bằng Facebook nghĩa là bản chất thực ra
mình gắn ở Sing A điểm gì bởi vì các bạn
thấy vụ đăng ký ở trên 10 cái trang web
bây giờ nó rất rườm rà
thế nên là thường Bây giờ nó và bây giờ
anh có tài khoản Facebook và Google nên
là sẽ có đăng nhập thông qua tài khoản a
Google hoặc Facebook 30w để nó sẽ lấy
được những cái thông tin cơ bản của mẹ
bạn cho phép
giống như lại email tên
Hòa cáo thậm chí ngày sinh giớitính
Hoàng ảnh đại diện nữa đấy thì những
người áp đấy phải xin quyền ở trên cái
trang Facebook đi lớp Ơ này bà nó sẽ
sinh ra một các lọn tóc em như thế này
đó sinh ra đoạn tóc em như thế này sau
đó vì nó sẽ gọi được đến grab của thằng
Facebook api của Facebook thì lấy thông
tin về giả sự như này
Vì vậy các bạn thấy lấy được thì vừa rồi
của tôi là tôi xin thêm một vài Quyến là
sự với tôi hệ xin thêm một vài cú nữa
các kiểu nhà có thêm có thể thêm nữa
nhưng mà hiện tại cái áp của tôi ra chỉ
có xin giờ này quyền thôi nếu mà các bạn
muốn tạo áp phải xin rất nhiều quyền để
làm hình như tính năng ấy thì các bạn sẽ
phải xin xin Facebook phải gửi sang phải
gửi lên sôi Facebook duyệt là kiểu ông
xin cái đây vì lý do gì thì đã lắng nhạc
Tết
A và thực ra là Facebook đó sẽ luôn hỏi
lại các bạn là việc là nó bạn có đồng ý
cho phép nó sử dụng cái cái gì đây không
mấy ông nên đọc thì mà kiểu nó mà hỏi
mấy ông cắt thứ thứ Quyền truy cập
thường mình không cần bấm nicknack ở đây
tôi biết mà
ở đây sau đó thì các bạn sẽ làm gì Các
bạn sẽ
nói chung là lấy được các thứ thứ như
này thì các bạn sẽ có thể là thật sự là
ở đây có fan đồng lưu vào rồi đây bấm
sắp ít em ạ
à à
ở
đây là chẳng qua là các bạn thấy thôi ca
nó đang không đủ quyền để bà lấy thông
tin bạn bé nghĩa là mình chỉ lấy số
lượng của bạn bè của mình thôi
Ừ nhưng mà Token full Quyền thì sẽ lấy
được hết
bây giờ mình sẽ đề cập đến lấy Token
full quyền là như thế nào các bạn sẽ lên
kệ trang vừa nãy mình có hỏi Nguyễn Anh
nhân Mình Anh Ngân là và bạn sinh năm
bao nhiêu ạ
Anh ở chùa cũng già trẻ tuổi bị nhớ Thế
chồng nhóm mình mình kiểu Anh không nhớ
ngày sinh các bạn làm đâu ạ
Ừ thì à à
ạ Bạn ấy bảo lên trang này sau đó thì
Ở trang này là trang của các admin của
fanpage
sau đó thì các bạn để
Ừ anh ở
anh
cân tonet tìm access Token
F12 nhá Ừ
à à
Ở đây các bạn Mẹ đây ạ
vì
vậy ông mà để lộ ra đây ra là mấy đấy
à à
cô
giáo stalker
à à anh Thái
ạ sau đó thì mà sao rồi mấy ông có thể
kiểm tra đầu tiên thì mày ông có thể
kiểm tra chương trình Cái tool của
Facebook kể Accent camber debugger này
kiểm tra xem Token này còn quyền hay
không có những quyền gì các từ thứ
ở
đây tokina Token Pearl hết hạn này Xuân
Quyền
ở phần quyền các thứ
Ê bà tao nghe này tao tao kem của user
nó sẽ có 2 loại tóc em đó là to kem của
người dùng mà to kem của Admin page điều
này to kem của loại người dùng bởi vì
tại sao mình có đề cập vụ đấy người vì
đối với số nhưng nó sẽ phân biệt người
dùng với test đó như nhau Nó là thế nên
là hồi trước mà có vụ là đổi tứ người
dùng sang fanpage được đối với Facebook
thì nó sẽ hiểu người dùng với fanpage ở
như nhau nha
Nên Liên là nó sẽ có 2 loại tóc em luôn
vào tóc em cho admin của fanpage và to
kem của người dùng
Ừ
[âm nhạc]
nhưng ở đây là tao kem mới dùng
khoảng cách gì mà các bạn xem thông tin
của người dùng này thì các bạn sẽ là
kiểu ngay họ chấm sét tao kem này
Ừ tí tôi sẽ vô hiệu hóa tài khoản tôi mà
Thì vợ mà trong thời gian livestream làm
với ông cũng khách hôm đi cả gà nãy giờ
mấy ông vẫn chưa xem được cái gì đâu với
ông thách mày ông hơn ngồi gõ ra đừng
anh như thế à
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
ở đây nói chỗ ở đây là để lấy thông khi
mà gõ kiểu như này nó sẽ lấy ra được
thông tin các bạn sẽ nghĩ là nó sẽ Chỉ
ra mỗi nên đi thôi đúng ạ Không nó sẽ
lấy ra được nhiều hơn cơ bạn sẽ chuyển
được Phi ở trong này sau đó đi lấy ra
luôn Nãy có đi Cập để cả quen hai đứa gì
đó thì đây là sự mình có thể lấy cột
location nó chẳng lại
và sự ra như thế này thậm Chưa acacia
nữa các bạn sẽ phải dokyson And I
khi sex
ở đó thì nó sẽ ra cả trường mình đã học
với Vân Vân Vân này các bạn sẽ thấy nó
luôn đi kèm thêm cái ID gì gì đó rất
tiện ở đây về sau Các bạn nhớ về vụ Hồi
trước và mình lại tất cả những bạn gái
xinh tất cả những bạn là con gái ở Hà
Nội không ạ Đó là tôi theo cái đi đấy
tôi sẽ cha đứa bé đi đấy lấy ra được
ờ ờ
là sử là mình sẽ lấy fan nữa ạ danh sách
bạn bè cũng được
lỗi em Hà Đông sọc chéo chứ tôi sẽ là
hoa chấm như này có mấy ông sẽ thấy à và
sẽ ra được nha
nếu mà thực ra như này vẫn chưa đủ thông
tin mình có thể lấy thêm được nữa là
mình lại thêm few nhà
sau đó thì location ngay Trả lại để lấy
ra được
chú chó
I mean thể lấy thêm nhé là sự tôi sẽ lấy
hội đấy tôi là như sẽ lạ nêm này chúc em
đâu rồi tính này cho location nè
Ừ nó hiện ra à
ở đó hót
mail rồi Hồ Chí Minh đóng xong rồi à
à à
Ừ thôi đấy tôi nhờ đó là render là sau
đó thì có thể lấy thêm ví dụ là sự làm
mấy ông thấy mặc định nó luôn trả lời
hai năm nữa ạ với ông sẽ lấy thêm đi mít
mình thể tăng lên hồi đấy là Rimix Hồi
đấy Limit được tăng vãi và Lê 5.000 khâu
Nhưng mà từ hồi Facebook bị mấy cái bài
phốt đi Tự nhiên hình như nó giới hạn
luôn cả cái bi ai đó sẽ lấy được ít hơn
nó không còn là 5.000 nữa
Ừ
vậy cái nó chỉ lấy được Kiểu mình nhớ
được 500 1000 thì thôi Mình đang chỉ để
mô 50 sau đó nhanh đấy lại khá như thế
này đây là fan các thứ lúc quá chứ thực
ra là mấy ông phải làm hơn được đấy thôi
Cho miếng xem
thế
này vào tháng nhóm minh luôn đúng không
ạ
Em
đổi cái này hãy chữ m này
Ừ đợi tí
em không thấy có ai đi đây không ạ tôi
đội này ai đi à
Xong rồi mai mờ này
xong phim rồi trên đâu rồi Em đâu rồi
ờ ờ
anh chứng tỏ là Token này đã bị thiếu
Quyền Thiếu quyền đấy mà truy cập được
vào
ờ ờ đúng rồi người ta phải công khai giờ
Nói chung là người ta không thay thông
tin gì mình mới lấy được
Ừ
chứ mình không có chuyện là kiểu
Đúng rồi tao ke này ra không có quyền
chắc à
nhà mình có thể ra được cái có quyền đấy
Mình hình như mình có cái vụ để ra được
cái cậu có quyền để mình xem nhé Mình
không
à à
Ừ mình không công khai ở bên này được
Anh sợ sợ mèo lạnh Đợi mình tí mình sang
phạm tạt bên bên này thử xem à
[âm nhạc]
Cho tôi công khai mấy cái tô cad admin
Birthday chết
vào khách chết à gọn
à à
ừ ừ
chỉ có vậy vẫn không lấy được
xe chở chở mình sẽ phải đấy đấy thì cái
Token cho Ken à
khi chọn nhìn paste nó lại một amin
group lại một cái tóc em nữa bạn
hãy cho lại khái à là
Ê hồi nãy mình làm được cái trò này hồi
đấy thằng Facebook nó không công khai mà
không cần giới hạn nhiều cái như thế này
đây lấy được cả
Ê hồi đấy con lấy lấy được cả những
người đã theo đã tương tác hay theo dõi
fanpage khác nữa cơ
Còn bây giờ thì chỉ có admin của fanpage
đầy mới được phép lấy qua rap như này
lấy thông tin Thôi nếu mà grab này mà
vẫn chỉ là một mức tướng đồ nữa nhé Vẫn
chưa một mức tương đối
thực tế các bạn sẽ có thể nói là em vào
trên khác ở trên điện thoại hoặc và bằng
máy tính của em em vẫn xem được xem được
thông tin của thông tin của người khác
cơ mà đúng ạ
Bố Mẹ anh bảo là rõ ràng tóc Cái này là
tao Zenfone quyền mà tại sao em dùng to
pen này qua grab này em lại không lấy
được thông tin rồi đấy và trong khi đó
là em em em
vẫn em vẫn có thể vào xem được nick
người ta vẫn xem được thông tin về ra
bình thường cơ mà không Bởi vì qua Lab
này là grab này là chị hỗ trợ cho thằng
đi lớp ơi nó làm những cái tình đang
phát triển cá thứ còn nếu hơn mấy ông
muốn thực sự là muốn lấy được thông tin
một người ta thì cái đường link không
phải được link grab này đâu đừng lên
chuẩn đó đường link của những cảnh afian
của thằng Facebook là nằm trong áp ở
trên điện thoại để mà lấy thông tin
người dùng cơ Cái vụ đấy thì mình đã
không không không thể chia sẻ các bạn
được của việc cái vụ đấy là vì Thảo chị
em mình và cái này là api ẩn của đóng
Facebook
Bí Ẩn đã gọi là ẩn Tức là không định
công khai bởi vì công khai xong nó lại
ngồi sửa thì lại mất công cho bọn mình
đúng không ạ
nhưng lại khá là qua grab này về ông có
thể làm được những cái nó đang hiện tại
đang có hình đó chỉ là qua Thế mày ông
dễ hình dung và có thể làm rất nhiều thứ
hồi khôi một mình làm công nhận cũng đã
làm hơn rất nhiều tự chia sẻ các bạn
trên cái ghế khác của mình bây giờ thành
ra rất nhiều cái tool của mình hồi đấy
không dùng nữa với đó là bị giới hạn như
thế này thôi Đấy mình chia sẻ rất nhiều
em coi đấy lấy được à
cho tất cả những người đào tương tác với
mình để tất cả những thành viên này Xóa
thành viên qua api có hết này đúng không
ạ
cách tải ảnh từ thứ còn hiện tại thì tra
bây giờ trên trang cá nhân chủ yếu thì
ổn hơn à
à à
à À quên đây là tôi vừa lấy đó có kén
của fanpage
Tôi dùng loại Token cá nhân à
hai
tay mẹ không thấy ra được như này có vẻ
hơi ít thông tin thỳ thôy K là cái này
có thể lấy được thêm đấy có lấy thêm
được là
cái này không bị nhược điểm một tí là
mấy cũng phải cũng ngồi mò nhiều
đây mình sẽ thêm cái phải max ít thì
tách mình là tất cả những cái đính kèm
và sẽ có cả linh à
Xin link nhạc
ở đó
Ừ tao xảy ra anh
phụ
kiện nhạc Đông ạ ạ
anh ấy tôi vẫn còn nhớ mua vài phim của
nó nhưng hai mấy ông muốn tra thêm những
cái phim đó thì các bạn lên cái như mình
vừa đề cập là lên cái
I rap của thằng này thì mà xem qua những
phim có thể có thể có tiềm mấy ông ấy gõ
thủ công và còn nếu mà không gõ thì nó
sẽ chỉ ra những cái phi công cơ bản
giống như vừa rồi là miset cái đi các
thử thôi
Ơ
cái thằng bên này Bay Mưa đâu vậy
cài đặt béo thể trả béo thể tìm qua
những cái phim về còn hơn rất nhiều cái
để lấy dâm đái xong béo bia là trong cái
phi ở đây này thì nó ra thêm những công
ty nữa lấy
à à
Ai có tool nào để vào xem để biết ai vào
xem cả trang cá nhân mình không
từng có người họ Vũ này hình như bị tư
trả lời rồi còn trả lời vẫn là không Ê
thằng Facebook không lưu được giấy để
trong mấy ông có thể biết về đâu cũng là
mấy ông kiểu vì hận tiểu sử là ai vào
Facebook của tôi thì
em chỉ là con chó chả để đó vào nhắn
chưa gì lại nghe đại khái Thế thì
vẫn được
chứ không Không có thằng nào lưu cho
người yêu đấy Mình không biết được
à Còn nếu nếu không thì ông vậy Khách
nào Facebook nó vợ chèn thêm của đoạn
Script vào trong cái trang cá nhân uống
để mỗi lần
mỗi lần ai vào trang người nhân ống đợi
Swift về đó sẽ được khi hoạt để mà
để mà kiểu tự động thông báo với chỗ thế
thôi
à à
3000 mày kể trên mạng đều chém gió đấy
không có cái gì đâu nó sâu ra À đúng rồi
cũng béo đây cà phê vụ đó sâu ra một
loạt lẽ đi Đúng không Nó lừa đấy mày cái
đi lấy miếu mẹ đi Ông đã từng gương Bác
với những người ấy thôi
anh không không phải là vào Facebook
mình nhiều nhất đâu linh tinh đấy
ạ Bây giờ Bây giờ giả sử tôi vào nick
của mấy ông không ra ID của tôi đâu Tôi
đảm bảo luôn
Ừ tôi đã bảo không là không rồi mấy ông
còn đùa tôi
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi đấy ib ai đi rồi những người
mình đã inbox gần đây
Ừ Ok nếu mà thắc mắc gì đâu
ai cho mày chia sẻ thế cho ca cũng không
đến nỗi dài lắm nha
Ồ
không Tôi tôi xuống máy này ốm Hôm nay
tôi đỡ rồi chẳng qua là giọng nó đang
hơi bị
thì hơi khó cả vẫn còn họ thì thôi
ờ ờ
ờ đi mua Nãy giờ tôi đang bỏ qua mấy cái
vụ như thế này rồi vấn đề mô thì mấy ông
ạ
ở đây để làm mấy cái demo này mà lấy
thông tin tưởng ngày thật ra là trên cốt
của tôi có rồi nhưng không dán vào cốt
của tôi
tham khảo trên chính cốt của tôi còn bé
để tôi cốt là năm cái tôn thì ra
nó hơi bị tốn thời gian một tí và và Cái
quan trọng là cũng hơi khó hiểu cho mình
các bạn vào mà chưa chưa biết về anh
biết ai lắm cho tôi chưa thôi chưa định
để mô cốt ngay bây giờ
à à
ông cha để tôi tôi đang cân nhắc thời vụ
là chủ nhật tuần này tôi có thể làm tung
nhưng mà trước cũng chưa biết là học cái
tút gì con phải ngồi xem lại xem mà
thằng Facebook nó có nó giới hạn vừa rồi
vừa rồi các bạn vừa thấy đấy nó Giới Hạn
Nào thằng rồi không biết được cả fanpage
nó sẽ nhà vân vân Nhưng nữa cho tôi dậy
thử kép sau
à à
à À đấy có ông kia hỏi về cái kênh nào
để dạy về Facebook không Thực ra là hình
như là rất ít canh dậy rồi mấy cái này
vì bản chất là cái này nó
đi qua quá trình tài liệu của thằng
Facebook thì nó nó có nhưng mà có nhiều
cái có không có chế tài liệu của nó và
mò là vẫn rocker và ít người
Anh dạy về cái này cục
kiểu bồn kìa Người ta mò được ra rồi cái
51 giữ cho riêng mình giống như vừa nãy
mình có đây cập đấy em một Giữ riêng
mình bởi vì thằng Facebook nó thường
thay đổi thay đổi liên tục Các bạn thấy
bây giờ nó lên thôi Đấy mình mò nhé
flash này nó chỉ còn là vơ rừng bay với
rừng 4 đi ballet Hàn vô rừng 12 rồi Tức
là thay đổi rất nhiều rồi Rảnh ra là các
bạn sẽ hiểu là rất ít ai chia sẻ cái này
rất ít ai luôn
Ừ mình cảm thấy mình chia sẻ cái này rõ
cũng có thể còn nguy hiểm nữa hơi sai
nữa Và đậy Facebook có thể ghét mình nữa
Facebook từng cho bay màu nick của anh
nhân cũng vì anh nhầm làm tung ra Cú với
ạ
khi gà đỏ rất là nguy hiểm thì phải cái
này à
Tự nhiên mày ông làm này cho làm vui
thôi nha mày không làm mình cái này xã
làm vui thôi Mày không làm cái này để
kiếm tiền nó hư thứ và dùng chính tao
khen mày ông rất hiện bởi vì ạ bởi vì
kiểu mấy ông gồm có kem của mấy ông spam
nhiều quá nó sẽ thứ nhất là nó sẽ khóa
nick âm có thể thay thế và nó vô hiệu
hóa quyền để cho béo máy to Kem khó hay
là không gọi được grab này nữa bởi vì có
cái vụ là giống như vừa nãy mình có đề
cập với cả lính mí đúng ạ Nếu mic của bị
giới hạn quá thì ông lít nó cũng rất là
ít
ô ô nó không luôn này lipid được nhiều
đâu Kiểu thế
tiền hàng ra nếu mà mày mò vui thôi nếu
không làm tool cái này kiếm tiền hay các
hư thứ
sẽ rất là vẫn phải làm mạnh về Hồi trước
mình mình làm cái hồi Mở Facebook cho bị
dính phốt đúng không dễ thở Tí hồi vào
Facebook mới bị gì mà có xong là ngoài
đời mình làm ở công ty cũng ngoài đường
34 tháng chẳng làm được bất kỳ luôn vui
vẻ dùng quá nhiều anh trai của hãng
Facebook mà Facebook Hồi đấy chặn hết
luôn chặn cả chán boss chẳng các thứ thứ
qua api vào facebook trả lời cái gì cả
ở chỗ ngã 4 hàng xanh làm những gì cả
mấy ông đừng có tham Hồ đi sâu quá
Ừ cái này dựa trên Thằng thứ ba mà nó
nhận thằng thứ ba là có vấn đề gì đó thì
mình nghĩ nhỉ Thế là không thế nên là
tôi mới bỏ Facebook làm tôn Facebook
chắc ơi bị khỏe hơn 2 năm rồi đấy bài
đăng nhập cuối là hai năm trước này à
à à
Vì thế nên là
Ừ có gì tôi sẽ chia sẻ cho mấy ông vậy
mấy cái mẹ với giống như dùng ra Speed
để mà làm chạy một cái gì đó cha cũng để
một cái gì đó thật là nó rất là tự động
thì làm Facebook nó vẫn có nhiều cách
thì nó xác định Xem ông có đang tự động
chạy cái lợn do Switch là trại lợn quyết
màu đó không nhưng mà mình có thể chơi
cho câu thời gian thêm một tí
Ừ nếu không có biết vụ đấy ạ nghĩa là
mấy ông có thể là
giả sử là thay vì mấy ông gọi qua grab
như này ngồi xóa tất cả bài đăng của ông
bởi vì a chạy qua grab ngày ông xóa hết
tâm
50 60 bài lập tức là nó sẽ quá các em
của ông mình nghi ngờ nên không bị hack
rồi thì mấy ông có thể chứa trò làm với
ông chạy ra Swift kiểu ngay
sau đó đi nó sẽ hiểu bản chất nó ra
Speed và sẽ gọi đến cái nút này sôi lấy
cái nút Delete này hiểu không đấy sau đó
sẽ chạy kìa tầm mà 2 phút 1 lần sau nếu
mua Cắm máy ở đây kiểu như thế nó sẽ
ngồi kéo xuống sao cứ thấy bài đăng nào
Bấm Xóa hạnh phúc một lần được như thế
2 phút thì được ra hơi quá và hơi lâu
nhưng mà anh nói chút ông mà càng làm
nhanh cho 5 giây một lần với một giây
một lần thì chả thấy Facebook rồi khóa
ngang ấp ông nhiều không em
Ê bà thật chứa một ngày ông chỉ muốn xóa
tập 100 bài là các ngôi được rồi Thế thì
nó sẽ an toàn
ở đây mình đã nói rồi đó là làm thằng
Facebook này thì đó cái thay đổi một cái
bất thương chẳng ai có thể lên bài viết
một cái gì đó chắc chắn về thấu Facebook
cả bởi vì kiểu gì đó sẽ sớm sửa một cái
gì đó
à à
thì
nó sẽ sửa của cái gì đó làm cho kiểu
khi tung của không dùng được nữa
Ừ ok và chùa buổi hôm nay có vẻ là cũng
chia sẻ tương đối rồi Đúng bạn chắc à Có
gì còn làm bài tập nữa
ừ ừ
thì các bạn còn thắc mắc gì quá Tuổi 120
mấy người xem mấy ông chỉ chơi giây phút
này thôi đúng không
bộ
quà tặng mà Hẹn gặp các bạn buổi sau nhé
Chào bạn nha
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]